yes sir i saw a reddit post that was
like um
uh it was like uh
uh what's the guy who made uh wrote game
of thrones uh george robin yeah george r
martin he was like he apparently begged
hbo to make ten seasons of game of
thrones instead of the says
you know and i went i you know i opened
this thread
i i half expected what do you think the
comments were going to be when you went
to that thread what would you think of
people would reply
get begging for 10 seasons yeah yeah you
apparently asked you would agree with
them they would agree like yeah go
george yeah maybe yeah no not at all
they were like they were like well if he
wasn't such a lazy piece of [ __ ] and
finished his books maybe we would maybe
we would uh you know we'd have something
to work off of apparently people suck
well i don't know because in some ways
apparently he
i can't remember what what exactly but
apparently he was helping writing some
episodes initially and then later on
afterwards he wasn't help helping write
any of the episodes you know isn't that
the reason why like the later seasons
sucked so much was that because he kind
of maybe that was that was that was a
theory right
now i've never seen a
and there was a lot of comments and
there's one or two that i kind of half
half agreed with where i was like okay
it's like all right
if you're not gonna do the job right and
you are the most qualified person for
the job
right
and they are doing it with or without
you yeah and you decide no i'm not doing
it and then it becomes [ __ ] yeah can you
then turn around and be like oh it's
[ __ ] they should have just given it more
time
because the argument was like if
someone's if the job's gonna get done
you're not gonna do it then it's your
fault yeah like it's kind of his fault
people were saying it's because he
should have it's it's not his fault i
mean it's not entirely i understand a
little bit where they were coming from
i'm sure there's like a certain degree
of responsibility but to say that it's
all his fault because he's like the main
guy is a little harsh i think a lot of
people were being very critical of him
in a sense that i thought was a bit
unfair
being critical no well i think this game
of thrones have gone to your the five
stages of grief with the books yeah yeah
they've like they've gotten to
acceptance now yeah yeah they've
accepted that it's never going to finish
and it's never coming out yeah like and
i'm pretty sure
the first time
i'm pretty i'm pretty sure it's like
never coming out like like as an anime
fan i'm like a hardened veteran i'm like
oh this series isn't finished cool give
me the next easter car just give me the
next finish
this is just like the one time where i
opened a reddit thread and i was
genuinely
incorrect on what i thought the replies
are going to be yeah right because
reddit is normally a really simple the
first thought that comes to your head
circle jerk yes like oh go for the low
hanging fruit get your karma yeah
everyone have votes yeah you know but it
wasn't that i was quite separate but i
also find with reddit it also depends
very much on the board you're on because
depending on the board you're on you can
get like very very different replies
because it's all like it's all like a
circle jerk but it's a circle jerk of
people who think alike and not everyone
on the same board thinks of life because
anyone who doesn't just gets shunned
yeah and so some i you know you go on
some reddit threads or some reddit you
know some reddit forums and you see like
this thread and you're like i can't be
the only one who thinks this way and
then you go on the reddit thread and
everyone seemingly in the reddit thread
thinks the exact opposite of you and
you're like am i the crazy one am i the
[ __ ] crazy one and then you see like
the same thing being discussed on
[ __ ] youtube or twitter or something
and it's a completely opposite opinion
yeah you know so i i think it very much
does depend on what board you're on and
what what kind of group of people you're
talking to
because i can't imagine everyone would
think that that is jaw george's fault
you know well yeah you know i was
thinking about it and as somebody does
creative stuff obviously not to the same
level and same expectations but you know
you you don't
it sucks because there are probably a
bunch of creators out there who are
legitimately just
being lazy and just like [ __ ]
chilling and not doing anything yeah
like uh whatever whatever and making
that you know and i guess in some ways
that raises the question of do the fans
have a right to demand the work come out
if he doesn't want to make it anymore
and it's halfway through is that i mean
i mean the issue is right the issue is
that
a lot of people
don't really appreciate how much time it
takes to make good [ __ ] yeah right um
i'm sorry joe i'm going to do i'm going
to do this again i'm going to bring up
arcane well once again i know okay yes
i thought you're going to say that yeah
i'm going to bring up arcane once again
joey
no because like you know that series
that series took six years to make right
from what i understand it took like five
or six years to make and it definitely
feels like it took five or six years to
make because there's so much like
attention to detail and like so many
different aspects of the show
but like so i can see that this took six
years to make at the same time would i
want to wait six years for a season two
i don't think i would you know i think i
would i'd because i his thing i don't
know what i would rather would i rather
wait that long for a better product or
would i rather wait
less time for a decent product that i
can at least
like carry like consume it's the [ __ ]
cyberpunk
it's it's [ __ ] cyberpunk
yeah
arcane 10 out of 10. go watch it weekly
reminder to go watch our game um number
two [ __ ] i don't know that's tough
because yeah yeah yeah would you would
you would you think cyberpunk would have
done better if they waited another two
years i think
with a game it's different because a
game is normally one and done like
cyberpunk would be one and done right
it's pretty much it's over right is it
yeah no because they can do updates yeah
yeah but like as in
the the core of the game there's not
going to be a cyberpunk 2
if you've played it there's not going to
be a cyberpunk 2. okay and if there
would i don't know what they would do
but it's going to be like a one thing
whereas like you know
uh arcane ended on a
cliffhanger yes right so when you're
ending on a cliffhanger it's a different
question as to post when you're done
like it's completely wrapped right yeah
cause that's why we can see it like
reboots like 10 15 years later cause
it's like okay it's this thing that's
done
and then oh
15 years later you like that thing this
is cyberpunk so 2078. right because like
it's done right it's done so it's it's
fine except it actually comes out in
the patch is 10 petrobites
[ __ ]
if it's a seasonal thing with multiple
seasons i don't want to wait six years
if it's if it's one thing that i don't i
don't know anything about yeah i can
wait 20 years because i don't give a
[ __ ] about it i don't know what it is
give me the thing that's done and
complete right yeah but now now that we
know there's probably gonna be season
two of arcane yeah i don't wanna wait
six years i don't i don't i don't i
don't even if it ends up being like
mediocre compared to season one i don't
i am fine with it going down from like a
ten out of ten to eight out of ten yeah
let me get it same here because there's
so much potential to this story where i
feel like it would be so squandered if
i'm 50 and i'm still like waiting for
part four of arcane yeah because like
because like i'm going through the same
dilemma now with awesome shokutense
because you know that
from what i've heard talking to people
in the industry that took so many
[ __ ] years to make and it definitely
shows that it took that many years to
make that's because of all the business
meetings
and that too
on top of that that was like seventy
percent
the studio did say that um they estimate
2023 for arcane season two 2023. that's
that's that's reasonable
yeah i feel like i feel like the reason
why they say six years because they
probably have those like pre-production
meetings that last like god god knows
how many years yeah like when you
actually start getting all the pieces
moving it's probably a little faster now
that you have more money more manpower
they know that it's a success we know
that it's very successful yeah it'll uh
you know and the merchandising is
endless probably with this and the games
and i i think i think we won't be having
any shortage of articles well they'll
have enough resources i'm sure i'm
pretty sure wright's going to give them
enough resources but i think one thing
that
one thing that isn't appreciated is that
you also need talent you know yeah
there's been enough anime projects that
have money thrown at it and it doesn't
help because there's just not enough
talent all like the talented people are
working on different projects right yeah
so it's i don't know it's it's it's a
dilemma i don't know i don't have the
right answers
yeah i'm begging you i'm begging you i
need it do you think cyberpunk's 2077
should have come out when it did
probably not but
how long how long would you have waited
for it because i remember because i
remember when they announced they were
delaying it right they delayed a lot of
people like king take your time brother
take your time the first time did they
first time they they delayed it
everyone's like you know what take your
time you made the witcher 3 i'll allow
it second time that was when people were
getting started to get aggie right now
that's when that's when patience was
tested so if they delayed it a third
time did they delay it a third time i
don't think i think the scope of the
game was just over ambitious
i think it was just too much yeah like
in this current day you can't make what
they were trying to make
to the level that they were advertising
yeah within a reasonable time because
you know the more the more you use you
sync into it there's only so many sales
you can get on a game without dlc and
battle passes and all that and it was
just gonna be a game with maybe dlc
right yeah maybe they'd get some
microtransactions in there but like
realistically it wasn't gonna be
anything that would crush numbers we'd
never seen before right yeah so like i
guess so i know it's it's like how do
you convince the investors to like stick
around and like be happy right because
you've got there's a lot of pressures
right from outside forces oh yeah it's a
business we can't forget and also is it
fair to ask people to spend like 10
years of their life on the same [ __ ]
thing
in some ways i'm like i guess they're
being paid because we like just 10 years
yeah yeah right well my monkeys are
built differently the japanese work
ethic is just saying that we just don't
we just don't have in the west this is
like
those dudes are like rookie numbers got
to pump them up yeah they are well i
mean in the case of the manga because
that's all they have even like iraqi
said right who did jojo right he he said
that the reason why he split it into
parts of generations is like he said i
would get bored drawing the same
characters for like 35 years yeah he had
the foresight to see that he would and i
don't blame him
could you imagine you gotta draw [ __ ]
mickey mouse like 150 times a day you
you blow your brain out
you'd know like the exact size yeah
you'd know the exact good size
can you imagine the [ __ ] jonathan was
still like the main character of jojo to
this day
yeah i'm actually even like you you
ended up like not even liking the
character you made after yeah yeah
exactly like you'd lose your mind yeah
yeah yeah you go crazy no that's that i
can relate to because as a youtuber i
always like working on something new you
know working on a new kind of content as
i'm sure you guys do as well right so i
can't imagine yeah also dedicating that
much time to just a single project and i
know there are people who have done that
you know especially in like indie video
games where it's just like a one-man
team working on this one game for
[ __ ] years